The joe rogan experience.
This is them push you like this,
a Mustang.
The more that the guy that trains the most the system is,
XML is the best.
You know,
every time,
every time you see,
look at this,
you just take four because I stay in the national team for
almost 15 [inaudible] 15 yeah,
15 years I staying in the Olympic Center.
Um,
you can imagine it.
It's Tay.
We that Tang guys for 15 years and they're 15 years Tang.
Guys,
I want to kill you.
You can.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Listen,
look what the song as soon building,
you know,
building,
he did a Mooc a quarter.
It's a building with a lot of rooms,
but I basically cannot quite a conference.
Come on.
What with you?
Sorry.
Look what that was again.
That's in my room.
That's it.
They ruined for the,
I'm not a guy,
but this guy is the same.
Damn.
I said division.
[inaudible] he can see it for 15 years.
Everything.
What are you're doing Addison,
where you eat every single you when you're sick.
Everything.
He know you are about everything.
Hmm.
So you live with your opponents.
They know when you're sick.
They know.
It's not like where when you're fighting a Matt Brown and he was,
he's in Kentucky and you're in Denver training.
Nobody knows what's going on there.
They train.
So you know what I'm doing.
I know what you're doing.
So we're all on the same floor.
They do it like that to build that,
you know,
whatever the hell that building versus for sure.
Come on.
Do you know how you prepare yourself mentally?
How do you
Tina,
but dad,
I'm in internet marketing.
You have to become a fucking machine.
But it's not only machine in the fight.
In the fight.
No,
no,
no.
My Shin and you life.
Yeah.
Femoral.
When you're sick,
she got her own beat.
The heck go to this guy.
No.
Only one.
He says gang guys,
you know,
do you think it were better than my monkey nut
in their yard?
A study or a mentee?
Yeah.
You got that.
Okay.
No,
you have to become a machine inside and out.
Those 10 guys know when you're sick.
They know when you get hurt.
So now I'm training with you,
but I saw that you hurt your wrist and training.
I'm going after fucking risk.
Right,
right,
right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's just,
it's,
it's intense.
So that's why he's the machine that he is.
He says it only trains you to be a machine on the outside but also trains you to
be a machine on the inside.
Well,
why would you do,
what can you do so easy?
I'm dropping 25% tax on Chinese Jana.
And you know,
I said to somebody that is really the messenger,
the Messenger is important.
I could have one man say we're going to tax you 25% and I can say another.
Listen,
your mother fuckers,
I'm telling you,
man,
look
not in favor of the wall.
I'm pro immigration that I'm not a favor of these ice busts and all that jazz.
But shit like that one's me over.
I said,
well,
I just love the fact that the guy's the fucking president.
And he said,
listen,
you motherfuckers,
you got to pay 25% taxes.
It says eight years before the campaign.
It doesn't say how many years.
Oh,
I love,
oh is it?
This is 2011 it's old,
but he looks the sense,
but what's funny,
I was talking about it on a stage.
It's still ridiculous.
I'm so tired of being yelled at by like online about people hate them.
Like listen,
I'm not a huge fan of them either,
but so many people are like,
I hate him.
I hate him that now.
I kind of liked him.
Exactly like,
do you know how enough people say Shit?
They're like,
fuck you.
I'm so tired of you telling me your opinion.
It's all the same to also,
what annoys me is when someone goes fucking moron.
That's like,
that's it.
That's all.
That's what you did.
You,
you,
you put like that's not doing anything by going,
hey Trump shuck my dick.
All right dude.
Well you got them.
Here's my take on that.
If it's that,
if it's fucking moron,
you're not even supposed to listen.
That's supposed to not even go in.
I know.
Cause there's not a,
this is not effective communication.
So if you engage that guy,
don't just completely waste your time.
Even if you get upset at you,
completely waste your time.
I wipe it away,
but I see it and I'm like,
oh,
come on.
This is the one that gets me as Nazi fucking Nazi Nazi.
Oh yeah,
he's a Nazi and you're a Nazi fascist.
They throw these words around.
They really don't even know what the fuck they're saying.
Like if you really think that everybody who looks likes Trump is a Nazi,
you're missing.
That's insane.
You're missing a giant point.
You're,
you're fucking up everything.
You're ruining this conversation.
You're right about a lot of the shitty does wrong here,
but as soon as you say he's a Nazi right,
and that there's Nazi,
everyone's a Nazi.
Well then when real Nazis come around have been to have a better name.
Yeah.
You can't really cook called Nazis.
He can't fucking take the word Nazi and applied to shit.
That's not Nazis.
That's dangerous.
Like people say like cost someone a murderer.
Why'd you call him a murderer?
Because he yelled and insult at that man.
Okay.
That's not a murderer.
Right?
But you can't do that.
Same thing with calling someone a Nazi.
That's not a Nazi.
He might be a moron.
He might be a fool.
He might be into Trump just because he's a dumb guy and he likes the fact
there's a white guy in office.
But that doesn't mean he's a Nazi.
But it's also like the biggest problem that I have is like you're,
it's still illegal to be an asshole.
It's not illegal to be a dick.
Right.
If someone's,
if someone says something you don't like where it's not against the law.
My,
my number one
concern with all this stuff is that I think it's happening so fast and so many
things are taking place in so many different realms when it comes to innovation
that this stuff will just catch up to us before we even recognize it's happened.
And it will be too late for sure.
I mean even just forget every single,
let's even just the whole,
uh,
atomic bomb see,
should allow for the last ever since we started from the 1940s to today,
there have been some seriously close calls.
There was a,
um,
did you remember to one that was wanting to 1980s,
I think right before the end of the Cold War where there was,
you know,
Russia,
the guy goes to his boring job where they are supposed to look for missiles from
the United States and nothing ever happened day after day after day.
And at one day there's a bleep on the radar and you're like,
oh shit.
And he's the guy,
he's jaw but to clearly superior.
And then if he does,
the outs are,
they are going to press the button it and he's like,
no,
no.
Wait,
let's come down.
Maybe this is wrong.
I made a concern,
not that stupid.
They will not send one atomic bomb before they do it.
They send a bunch.
So these must be a mistake.
Let's hold it,
relax three minutes later.
And other beliefs and other belief and other,
he's like,
Oh shit,
they're setting to get a bunch of atomic bombs.
These is the real deal.
And the guy,
Steele doesn't do what he's supposed to.
He's feels like if I make this call,
nuclear war starts,
I need to be [inaudible] was in percent convenes.
The evidence in front of them is pretty solid,
but I still don't feel it.
And then five minutes later all the beliefs go off.
It was a mistake on the radar and it was like some random bleep and uh,
the guy probably drank a bottle of vodka straight because he was like,
do you know the almost caused world war three?
Exactly.
And you know,
most off ours,
all their lives now to some Russian dude in the 1980s,
who decided not to do what he was supposed to.
And then because of the stupid mistake,
stupid bug in the radar,
that's a pretty open ended
description,
right?
Oh,
it's so open ended.
There were so many like weird performance art things that would happen.
We,
I mean,
we had performance art class.
There was a guy that like taped his genitals to the side and put on lipstick in
a mirror and that was his performance art piece or the girl that night and we
would all sit there and watch it.
Did you see his genitals?
Did he go naked and pull it aside or how did he do that?
That's a really good question.
And I like how your mind just went there.
You're like,
what actually happened?
I think I blocked it out
because I think you could probably get away with doing that under the guise of
it being something you're doing,
you know,
in a class somewhere.
Yes.
You get away with us.
So pervy I think I was focused on his beautiful lips.
I was trying to be polite and not look down there.
Another woman was obese and her was,
she had preset up.
We weren't it where she was doing the performance,
uh,
butter pats in like dominoes,
like a,
you know,
a few thousand of them in a line and she was obese and she crawled on the
ground.
She didn't actually eat them,
but it was something that's weird.
My mind kind of drops off.
I remember specific parts of it,
but I don't,
I think she just was collecting the butter pieces and crawling and that was her
performance.
These another guy,
uh,
the,
this was,
I went to Detroit and then finished in San Francisco.
And San Francisco is known for being a real performance art history.
A lot of the,
you know,
the most famous performance artist.
Nobody knows where that was.
The scene was in San Francisco.
So,
uh,
it was two story really beautiful campus overlooking,
you could see a Lombard street on one side.
You could see the water on the other side.
And uh,
another guy's piece was to jump from the second story to a tree just like that.
He may or may not have made the jump and that was his art,
his art pieces of jumping from a window to a tree.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I know this other guy,
the room where we had our class,
he had a bread machine.
This was back,
you know,
bread machines where new technology at a breadmaker,
you know those machines,
you can make it.
I guess it just does the dough,
right?
Or maybe it bakes it.
I think it just needs the dough.
And then you bake it,
or I don't know if you bake it in the machine or no,
you bake it in the machine.
It's all coming back to me.
He bakes it in the machine.
We come into the classroom as he's baking it,
there's always like a reveal and these pieces,
right?
So we come in,
he's taken plaster from the wall and put it in the bread.
He's Fed us the bread.
Half of us get it,
half of us don't.
And there's plaster and the bread.
Why do you put plaster and his bread?
It was something about communism.
Some good the bread,
some don't.
But even if you get the bread,
there's plaster.
And so in your face,
what the fuck?
Oh my God.